severe weather is being blamed for at
least two deaths in the Midwest in
Nashville about 40,000 people are waking
up without power several tornado
warnings were issued as high winds
uprooted trees and roofs and tore down
power lines the storm also sent several
tents set up for this weekend's
Nashville Pride Festival flying into the
air and landing on cars more rough
weather is expected in that area today
meteorologist Jeff beard le has a look
at the nation's weather Jeff good
morning good morning Jeff great to be
sharing the studio with you and good
morning everybody big heat dome in the
southeast and this Train of showers and
thunderstorms on the north side of it
that trend continues the whole weekend
Saturday and also into Sunday we have a
big dip in the jet stream entering the
West and would you believe with that
cool air in this jet stream it is
snowing in the mountains however with
the cold air versus the hot air we have
the collision zone and a lot of severe
weather that will be taking place both
today and also into tomorrow so let's
show you the future radar two
bull's-eyes one in the southeast one in
the plane States under the gun today
Oklahoma City Des Moines Kansas City
also another area towards Atlanta
overnight tonight watch out you might
wake up to the sound of thunder in
Dallas tomorrow morning and quiets down
but then eventually we're gonna see
another round of big-time showers and
thunderstorms tomorrow over the next
seven days the rain will continue to
saturate the places that do not need it
in the nation's middle and in the south
it is going to be mighty hot with
temperatures 90 to 100 all across the
southeast and the southwest as well
welcome to summer everybody still snow
in some places thank you